what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some pretty
mindblowing news that could possibly
make a lot of fans insanely happy there
is a lot of pressure right now writing
on a few specific movies that are coming
in the MCU movies that are supposed to
revitalize Marvel and give fans hope
again essentially saving the MCU as it
is right now not that it's terrible by
any means whatsoever but Marvel hasn't
really pumped out the same quality of
content that they used to and this is
widely due to having to create many new
Disney Plus shows whereas Marvel before
used to be hit after hit after hit now
we only get a hit every now and then so
Marvel is relying on movies like
Deadpool 3 Avengers 5 and Avengers
Secret Wars to just completely knock it
out of the park and as far as these
movies are concerned we have a really
exciting update that gives fans even
more hope if it all comes together it
should be pretty dang close to to
perfect Marvel Studios has basically
already taken their precautions to make
sure that Deadpool 3 is going to be
absolutely amazing plus Ryan Reynolds of
course wouldn't have it any other way
and now it seems like they've taken a
really great step towards ensuring that
Avengers Secret Wars is also going to be
the same it's just a rumor and
speculation for right now but it looks
like Phil Lord and Christopher Miller
might be in the running to be directors
for Avengers Secret Wars and Avengers 5
which still at this Point based off of
what we know has no name just Avengers 5
now if you are not familiar with who
these people are Phil Lord wrote
Spider-Man into the spiderverse and Phil
Lord and Christopher Miller both wrote
Spider-Man across the spiderverse both
of which are really great Multiverse
Spider-Man films if you haven't seen
those two films I highly suggest
checking them out now if this ends up
being true this is an insanely huge win
for us the fans for the MCU in general
but specifically for the movie and let
me explain why this should happen why
Marvel Studios should absolutely hire
Phil Lord and Christopher Miller to be
the directors and possibly also
additional screenwriters for Avengers 5
and Avengers Secret Wars and of course
if you're new be sure to subscribe to
the channel so you don't miss out on any
of the latest Marvel MCU news also doing
a giveaway more talk about that at the
end so Marvel Studios possibly hiring
Phil Lord and possibly Christopher
Miller with Phil Lord to direct possibly
screenwrite for Avengers Secret Wars is
very Marvel of them what I mean by that
is Marvel Studios has recently hired
directors or writers who have worked on
other kind of Multiverse projects before
the perfect example is Michael Waldren
and Jeff lovess they both worked on the
show Rick and Morty and that has a lot
of Multiverse elements to it a lot so
for the Multiverse Saga Kevin Figi hired
them to write some projects for them
that are heavily revolved around the
Multiverse for example example Michael
Waldren wrote Loki season 1 he also
wrote Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness and Jeff lovess wrote Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantum Mania all of which
really involved the Multiverse and
variants and Kevin fiky has hired
Michael Waldren to not only write
Avengers 5 but also Secret Wars as well
so that's one reason why this rumor
makes sense Phil Lord wrote two Marvel
films that were based on the Multiverse
and Christopher Miller joined Phil Lord
for across the spiderverse and recently
across the spiderverse has won a bunch
of awards and both were incredibly
successful at the box office and that
really just comes to the second reason
which is they know how to write a good
story that has a lot of different
characters in it there were a ton of
variants and Spider-Man iterations and
Spider-Man across the spiderverse when
we went to the hub we saw hundreds or
thousands of them all done extremely
well and put into a great overall story
which I believe is kind of the problem
that Marvel Studios has had recently
storytelling I think Marvel needs to fix
that one problem they need to make
better stories and it sounds like based
off of what Bob Iger said recently that
is now their main focus because it's one
thing to write or direct a film that's
based off of one main character and
possibly one main villain and a couple
of Side characters to support the hero
and the villain but writing a movie that
has a lot of different characters as the
main characters is a completely
different story it's a completely
different job and some people aren't up
to that however Phil Lord and
Christopher Miller have already proved
themselves like I said all around the
two spiderverse films are considered
massive successes and are really loved
by the fans if you don't count that
people were kind of upset about the
Cliffhanger and across the spiderverse
but overall that movie is amazing now
this rumor started because reliable
Insider my time to shine hello tweeted a
picture of Kevin fige and Phil Lord at
the critic's Choice Awards and she
captioned the Tweet with this one is
going to be more relevant than you think
so of course everybody naturally thought
oh my gosh Kevin foge is going to get
Phil Lord and possibly Christopher
Miller with him to direct the next two
Avengers films the reason people think
it's the next two Avengers films
Avengers 5 and Secret Wars not just
Secret Wars is because Kevin fige has
already hired Michael Waldren to write
both films since essentially Avengers 5
is going to be a part one to Avengers
Secret Wars it does make sense to have
the same writer for both of them and in
turn of course it makes complete and
total sense to have the same director
this is exactly what they did with
Avengers Infinity war and Avengers
endgame with the rousa brothers they did
both why to keep the continuity so the
second film can have the same feel as
the first that way it doesn't feel like
two completely different movies but
indeed does feel like a part one and a
part two having the part two pick up and
feel like we're picking up right after
the ending of part part one is critical
if Avengers Infinity War didn't end the
way it did then Avengers ingame pick up
the way it did then it just wouldn't
have felt the same so this is another
reason why this would be an incredibly
smart decision by Marvel Studios and
Kevin feige if they hire Phil Lord and
Christopher Miller they could direct
both just like they did for the
spiderverse film so far and here's
another reason that they should be hired
that many people might not have
considered they are kind of
perfectionists Phil Lord and Christopher
Miller for across the spiderverse would
change things all the time if they
thought it was going to be better now
this is both good and bad it was a
nightmare for the production team for
across the spiderverse across the
spiderverse and the next film Beyond the
spiderverse were supposed to essentially
be done at the same time they were
supposed to do everything at the same
time working on across the spiderverse
and Beyond at the same time however due
to all of the changes they weren't
really able to do that and now beyond
the spiderverse has been delayed it was
supposed to come out a year later and
now it's not now this unfortunately is a
double full EDG sword because Marvel
Studios hasn't exactly been the best at
this recently either they'll go into
projects and change things on a whim and
those projects end up not being too good
however there's a way that this will
easily work and that is they have to
finalize everything before they begin
production on it and I'm talking about
filming here we got a lot of okay Marvel
Studios projects recently but one
project that was absolutely amazing was
Loki season 2 and I've done a whole
video about this before so I won't go
too deep into it but basically what
happened was Loki the entire season 2
was written and finalized before filming
began there was only a couple of changes
they had to make but basically the whole
entire script for each episode was not
Rewritten again with the exception of
one episode but this allowed everything
to go super smoothly it also gave the
VFX team time they weren't rushed to fix
things or add new things or take away
some things this is why the VFX and Loki
looks so good so yes it is a little
concerning that Phil Lord and
Christopher Miller were changing things
almost daily for across the spiderverse
but there's a good way to look at this
one is that they are clearly requesting
things that they think will make the
movie amazing will make the movie better
and if you saw across the spiderverse
and into the spiderverse you know those
movies are fantastic and to be honest
it's hard for me to get super into
animated projects but I do really love
those movies The V effects are amazing
but the story is incredible so if they
are making some changes hopefully it's
for the good of the films and I think we
all agree that we want the best possible
films that we could get they also make
sure everything looks exactly the way
they want it to look and if they're
going to direct these films then that's
a really good thing so again if they can
just lock in almost everything before
they begin obviously there's always
changes as they go on the Fly some
things come up and there's improv Etc
but if they can do the best they can to
solidify and finalize everything before
they go into filming I think this would
be an incredible Choice they're well
experienced with the Multiverse in fact
their track record is great with the two
spiderverse films I think these two
could be the men for the job but let me
know what you think in the comments down
below do you think this is a good idea
would you like this would you not leave
your thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
please subscribe to the channel to stay
up to date on more news also if you
leave a comment and you subscribe you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items and some
DC items as well the winner picks one
item and we pick one winner at the end
of each month don't forget to find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof